ein marketingprofi im auftrag einer
shopping statt
hier bekommt jedes einkauf event seinen
eigenen namen
das haben wir organisiert nur für unsere
chinesische kunde mehr joggen noch mehr
chinesische kunden in süddeutsche
metzingen holen diese gruppe ist auf
einkaufstour in berlin prag und wien war
wie schon jetzt ist einkaufen angesagt
ich war schon gestern abend hier und wir
haben anderthalb tage heute will ich bis
20 uhr geheim
rund 500.000 chinesen kommen jedes jahr
nach metzingen von rund vier millionen
besuchern insgesamt über die outletcity
haben sie sich schon in shanghai
informiert wie wollen die label stores
mit den luxusmarken touristen aus aller
welt die einzelhändler hier in lernen
alles über ihren geschmack und ihre
mentalität und sie stellen
verkaufspersonal ein dass die richtigen
sprachen spricht für tourismus managerin
wo aber waren die letzten monate nicht
leicht diesen mehr chinesen in die
einkaufsstadt bringen doch die machen
sich sorgen wegen der terroranschläge in
deutschland und europa manche schrecken
vor der reise zurück
mein hunger ist eher dass ich die
richtige information über deutschland zu
berichten
genau hier habe auch also wir haben
nicht gesagt okay die geschichte jetzt
chinesische markt wird in terror und wir
haben mehr also ich war mehr in china
und ich habe auch mehr die kunden gesagt
wir in ganz normal hier und wir leben
ganz normal hier und bekenner immer noch
mehr so häufig komme
viele produkte sind in europa billiger
als zu hause in china denn da droht die
luxussteuer wer zum shoppen kommt hat
oft eine lange einkaufsliste die
verwandtschaft ist online und mit
konkreten bestellungen dabei
sie haben extrem viel geld also im exil
also kaufen sehr viel aber von den
zeiten hin werte unter druck so zu sagen
weil sie kommen nur für kurze zeit das
so 14.15 uhr
wie kaufe nicht viel ein und dann gehen
wird wieder rauer shopping auch bei
diesem paar ein anzug für 1000 euro und
einen koffer gleich dazu lieblingsmarke
hugo boss der deutsche herrenausstatter
war der erste fabrik shop in metzingen
nun soll der haut letzter weiter wachsen
zum größten postshop der welt fehlt noch
alipay frau will die geschäfte
überzeugend technisch aufzurüsten
der chinesische kunden sagt sie zahlen
in ihrer heimat längst mobil mit ihrem
handy ständig cities internationales
modalität nicht so üblich dass man
wechselt mitte handy in deutschland etwa
dieses geschäft hat sich schon
entschlossen technisch aufzurüsten
die chinesischen kunden sehen das als
wertschätzung
die beratungsfunktion auch haben und
nutzen es sofort die fans in einer
halbzeit ihrer shoppingtour
sie hat edle küchenmesser eines
deutschen herstellers gekauft dazu einen
gürtel für ihren mann der allein kostet
140 euro
die sachen wurden auch in europa
produziert und hier sind sie preiswerter
als zu hause
nach drei stunden hat sie für rund 600
euro eingekauft wie hoch ihr budget
insgesamt ist sagt sie nicht nur so viel
gekauft was ihr gefällt